ich habe eine idee heute üben wir das
werk haben
los geht's janus was hast du ich habe
ein problem welches problem hast du ich
habe kein geld hast du geld
ich habe auch kein geld aber vielleicht
hat francisco ja geld francisco schaut
nach ob er geld hat
francisco hat ein portemonnaie leider
hat francisco auch kein geld was hat
janosch hast du hunger
ja ich habe hunger und ich habe durst
lust hat hunger und durst janus hat eine
aufgabe
endlich hat janisch sein wohlverdientes
frühstück janosch hat einen kaffee und
ein marzipan croissant
ich habe lust mir einen neuen pullover
zu kaufen
dieser pullover hat schöne streifen
dieser pullover hat eine türkise farbe
und dieser pullover hat einen besonders
weichen stoff janus hat in zwei wochen
seinen sechzigsten geburtstag
janisch hat spaß daran all seine freunde
einzuladen francisco hat eine
geburtstagskarte für janosch janosch hat
angst dass keiner zu seiner
geburtstagsparty kommt hat schon mal
vorgesorgt er hat vier weinflaschen nein
janosch du kannst die nicht zum
geburtstag haben
ich habe eine peperoni pflanze in der
hand janosch hat lust eine peperoni zu
pflücken
janosch hast du deine schlüssel dabei
warte ja okay ich hab meinen schlüssel
in meine hosentasche maria was hast du
da ich habe ein spielplan von dem
lichtblick kino francisco und ich haben
einen schal aber keine mütze francisco
und janus haben immer einen witz auf
lager
wir hoffen ihr habt für heute das wort
haben genug geübt
wenn ihr noch mehr deutsche werben
kennen lernen wollt dann schaut doch mal
bei unserer app siedlung vorbei denn
dort gibt es einen vokabeltrainer mit
dem ihr noch neue übung machen könnt wir
haben auf jeden fall für heute genug
[Musik]